es un momento para la historia de Reino
Unido tras 70 años de reinado de Isabel
II con su muerte su hijo Carlos III fue
proclamado Rey oficialmente tras la
aprobación del Consejo de adhesión desde
el balcón del Palacio de
[Música]
clain proclamamos que el príncipe Carlos
philippe Arthur George debido a la
muerte de nuestra soberana se convierte
en el único legítimo Rey Carlos III por
la gracia de Dios Reino Unido Gran
Bretaña e Irlanda del Norte y de sus
otros reinos y territorios Rey jefe de
la commonwealth defensor de la fe a
quien le debemos fe y obediencia con
afecto humilde Esperamos que Dios por el
que Reyes y reinas reinan que bendiga a
Su Majestad con largos y felices años
para reinar sobre nosotros
Carlos III ya se había convertido en rey
de forma automática al morir su madre
pero la ceremonia del Consejo de
adhesión ha conformado por políticos
jueces y personalidades públicas que
ejercen consejeros del monarca lo
oficializa tiene un enorme valor
simbólico y constitucional que le
otorgan el legitimidad al rey quien
acompañado por su mujer Camila y por su
heredero al Trono William prometió
servir a Reino Unido
estoy al tanto de esta gran herencia y
de los deberes y grandes
responsabilidades de la monarquía que me
fueron ahora heredadas
Y al tomar estas responsabilidades debo
esforzarme en seguir el ejemplo
inspirador que se me ha dado
ahora su coronación podría tomar en
meses Isabel II fue coronada 16 meses
después de la muerte de su padre pero
debido a la avanzada edad de Carlos III
se espera que su ceremonia se lleva a
cabo con más celeridad